[Música]
en colombia siete de los principales
líderes desmovilizados de la antigua
guerrilla de las farc reconocieron su
rol en más de 20.000 secuestros
extorsivos por los que pidieron perdón a
las víctimas ya sus familiares
nuevo caso de violencia en mexico dos
sacerdotes jesuitas fueron asesinados en
el estado de chihuahua caso se enmarca
en una serie de asesinatos que han
aumentado en el país este año mayo se
convirtió en el mes más violento de 2022
se extiende la incertidumbre sobre el
futuro del aborto en eeuu la corte
suprema de justicia aplazó la decisión
que estaba prevista que se tomara este
martes mientras grupos de activistas se
manifestaron en las inmediaciones de la
sede del supremo
vale bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muños empezamos en colombia siete
de los principales líderes
desmovilizados de la antigua guerrilla
de las farc reconocieron su rol en más
de 20.000 secuestros extorsivos con
fines políticos por los que pidieron
perdón a las víctimas ya sus familiares
el hecho ocurrió en una audiencia de
reconocimiento bajo la mediación de la
jurisdicción especial para la paz
conocida como la gente
una imagen imposible sin el acuerdo de
paz de 2016 este marte a siete de los
principales líderes desmovilizados de la
guerrilla del frente armado
revolucionario de colombia farc se
sentaron frente a las víctimas de
secuestro en un acto de reconciliación y
verdad trece años estuvo en cautiverio
el sargento césar lazo que mostró las
cadenas que le pusieron sus captores
porque las cadenas de la humillación
amarrada al cuello
a un compañero
nos causamos
la mayor de las humillaciones por
primera vez el último comandante de la
ex guerrilla conocido como alias
timochenko reconoció su papel en la toma
de rehenes al menos 21 mil 396 víctimas
oficiales principalmente entre 1993 y
2012 y manifestó su deseo de reparar el
daño
nuestra responsabilidad individual y
colectiva
frente a uno de los más abominables
crímenes cometidos por nuestra
organización
fruto de una política que desembocó en
crímenes de lesa humanidad y crímenes de
guerra yendo en contravía de los valores
y los principios que preguntaban
inspiraban nuestra lucha unos hechos que
según las víctimas y sus familiares dejó
huellas imborrables desde el anhelo de
pasar página' exigen la verdad integral
yo creo que no hay nada mejor y
reconfortante para una víctima en medio
de tanto dolor
es que se le diga la verdad las
audiencias públicas en la red
continuarán hasta el jueves con el fin
de darle la participación al mayor
número de víctimas
[Música]
en pero un grupo de pescadores se reunió
frente a la embajada española reclamando
a la empresa repsol por no haberles
pagado la indemnización prometida por el
derrame de petróleo ha ocurrido en
ventanilla a 30 kilómetros de la capital
del país y que ocurrió el pasado mes de
febrero el gobierno peruano lo catalogó
como la peor emergencia ambiental en la
historia reciente del país manuel a cano
con los detalles
ollas vacías y gritos que denuncian en
cumplimientos varios pescadores se
reunieron frente a la embajada española
en perú para pedir la compensación
prometida por la compañía repsol debido
al derrame de petróleo ocurrido el 15 de
enero a 30 kilómetros de la capital el
grupo demandaba una indemnización que
aseguran no ha llegado y relatan los
desafíos a los que se han visto
sometidos desde la emergencia ambiental
a raíz del derrame del petróleo nosotros
hemos sido afectados enormemente igual
que los pescadores artesanales del
puerto la cual la empresa repsol no
quiere reconocer eso y ellos dicen que
solamente son afectados directos los
pescadores artesanales la cual no es
todos somos una cadena nosotros vivíamos
nos trataban nos abastecíamos con los
productos netamente del puerto de
chancay el hecho fue catalogado por el
gobierno peruano como el peor desastre
ambiental de su historia reciente y el
martes pasado una comisión del gobierno
aseguró que deficiencias en el proceso
de descarga de petróleo agravaron el
derrame
tras tres meses de investigación sobre
el derrame de petróleo ocurrido el 15 de
enero en ventanilla sede pueblos del
congreso de perú determinó que el
desastre ambiental fue causado por las
malas maniobras por parte de la
refinería la pampilla de la empresa
repsol
seis mil barriles de petróleo se
filtraron en el océano peruano en la
refinería la pampilla de repsol la más
grande del país a pesar de que el
gobierno ha multado en seis ocasiones a
la multinacional los pescadores y las
familias del puerto chancay aseguran que
éstas no han sido suficientes
vamos a méxico donde la ola de violencia
sigue en aumento este lunes dos
sacerdotes jesuitas fueron asesinados en
el estado de chihuahua y sus cuerpos se
encuentran desaparecidos el caso se da
justo cuando el gobierno reportó que
mayo fue el mes más violento de 2022 con
dos mil 833 homicidios registrados
previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal en la capital mexicana
mario carbonell quien nos contó a qué se
debe esta alza de homicidios hubo un
incremento del mes de mayo respecto de
abril de un 16% con lo que se convierte
en el mes más violento de 2022 con más
de número de homicidios y se supera ya
los 121 mil homicidios dolosos que es
más que el total de homicidios cometidos
durante el sexenio de felipe calderón
cuando se desató la llamada guerra
contra el narcotráfico las autoridades
aseguran que si bien hubo un incremento
en mayo se trata del mes de mayo con más
bajas cifra de homicidios en los últimos
cinco años y también representa una
disminución respecto del máximo
histórico en 2018
el presidente de lópez obrador asegura
que los homicidios se dan allí donde hay
pugnas de grupos rivales y enfocan en la
mayor cantidad de asesinatos en seis
estados de la republica precisamente con
estas pugnas
en eeuu se llevó a cabo el cuarto día de
audiencias en el congreso sobre el
asalto al capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 por parte de los seguidores del ex
presidente de donald trump la jornada de
hoy contó con el testimonio de
funcionarios estatales quienes
describieron cómo se encontraron bajo la
presión del ex mandatario y su abogado
rudy giuliani para revertir los
resultados que le dieron la victoria a
job háyder en sus respectivos estados en
un intento por aferrarse al poder
hoy demostraremos que lo que le sucedió
a mike pence no fue una parte aislada
del plan de donald trump para anular las
elecciones
de hecho presionar a los servidores
públicos para que traicionen su
juramento fue una parte fundamental del
libro de jugadas y un puñado de
funcionarios electorales en varios
estados clave se interpusieron entre
donald trump y el cambio radical de la
democracia estadounidense
ante
la corte suprema de justicia de eeuu
vivió una tensa jornada en sus
inmediaciones este 21 de junio estaba
previsto que el alto tribunal se
pronunciará sobre el derecho al aborto
en el país
la cuestión que reunió a decenas de
defensores y también detractores que
protagonizaron protestas aunque
finalmente los magistrados optaron por
aplazar la decisión para evitar
confrontaciones
la decisión de la corte suprema de eeuu
sobre el futuro del aborto tendrá que
esperar en el alto tribunal amaneció
fortificado entre vallas y seguridad
ante lo que podría ser un
pronunciamiento histórico sobre este
derecho los magistrados están analizando
la validez del caso roe versus weight de
1973 que legalizó la práctica en eeuu
algo que ha generado una gran
controversia
y actualmente no parece que eeuu vaya en
una buena dirección el gobierno busca
controlar nuestros cuerpos buscan
controlarnos y evitar que vivamos vidas
libres llenas de opciones donde podamos
decidir el resultado y el destino de
nuestras vidas y no estamos de acuerdo
con eso
en el exterior se concentraron decenas
de defensores y detractores e incluso se
llegaron a vivir momentos de
enfrentamiento entre ellos la filtración
de un borrador de la corte suprema- en
el que se revocaría el roe versus wave
encendió todas las alarmas el pasado 3
de mayo llegando a temer que este
tribunal de mayoría conservadora tumbe
el derecho al aborto
con la filtración que salió a principios
de primavera esperamos que eso sea lo
que mantenga la corte ahora la uach es
de tegel que regresen reexaminen roe
versus wave y lo reviertan eso
significaría que no habría más fallos
federales en eeuu sobre el aborto o
networks en además de la decisión sobre
el aborto la corte suspendió otros temas
importantes como el intento de revocar
el control del porte de armas en nueva
york todo un esfuerzo por no agitar más
un ambiente político ya tenso por
investigaciones como la del asalto al
capitolio
y 7000 personas participaron en una
clase de yoga gratuita y masiva en la
ciudad de nueva york este martes se
celebró el día mundial de esta práctica
promovida por india como una forma de
paz en un mundo caótico los ciudadanos
aprovecharon el espacio que coincidió
además con el solsticio de verano el día
más largo del año para el hemisferio
norte del planeta
de esta manera despedimos a esta
informativa en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos los invitamos a que
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]